chapman automotive the sponsors of this
segment they continue to win and when
they win so does the community so
joining us now is don hamrick president
of nevada operations to tell us what's
new hey don how you doing welcome back
welcome back so let's talk about it
number one again
tell us all about it it's not boring to
us okay i know but yes we're pretty
excited and so we had a lot going on
last month moved into a brand new
building so for us to be able to
continue to depend defend our title and
we beat our next closest competitor by
over a hundred units so you know we
shall not speak of no we done pretty
good we did pretty good girl that's
awesome okay and now obviously the
problem across the board of the
automotive industry has been inventory
yeah so part of why you guys are still
number one is because that's not an
issue for you we do have the cars and so
uh having invested all this money to
build a new dealership
we got extra inventory for our customers
and so the other problem is like you
said inventory is light so the dealers
that have them are charging a lot for
them right we're not in that position
i've got extra inventory we're making
great deals for customers and it's been
effective people are very happy okay i'm
off to come see you guys yeah we'll make
that happen now obviously car owner
responsibility taking the car to get
serviced and with that new facility
comes a beautiful state-of-the-art car
service area the service department's
amazing so uh 36 000 square feet they're
showing a picture of that look at how
amazing oh yeah all our techs have it's
nice their own tool boxes it is uh
heated and air conditioned nice big
brake area and um so far our customers
are loving it we're actually letting
them tour that you normally don't see
the back of the house right we're
letting them see that because it is so
doggone pretty yeah and we're getting
cars repaired in record times and
running with a 970 csi my customers are
very happy and that's what we want okay
happy customers now
do you have to get the car from chapman
in order to use that fine establishment
or no no but here's what will happen if
you come in and use this once you're
going to use this again i like that
actually
we're open for every um if you bought
from another dealership hey we
understand those things happen and what
you'll find is you'll come into our shop
you'll be greeted warmly and we'll get
your car repaired back to you quickly
and maybe the next time you'll consider
us
okay and last time you were here we're
talking about free gas yeah really quick
we've got about 30 seconds are you still
doing that we're still doing free gas 90
days worth of free gas 90 days no
payments zero percent interest for 72
months you're hearing all the interest
rates going up guess what baby not at
chapman yeah well no wonder you're
number one thank you so much don thank
you the champion automotive for
sponsoring this segment call
702-457-1000
or just visit las vegas dodge dot com
remember that special offer free ride
for 90 days and no payments and free gas
for 90 days with a new purchase car or
lease